bis zu 20% leidet unter Prokrastination
das ist nicht auf einen ekliger Fußpilz
sondern Eigenschaft dass man Sachen
wirklich wichtig wäre du und aufschiebt
man auch Aufschieberitis und warum das
eine
[Musik]
haben wir das ist Fleisch und Bossard
heute zum prokrastinationen
sogar
das Problem ist desto eher so Team Peach
Weber was ich heute kann besorgen geht
genauso gut auch morgen definitiv
ich bin
sehr lästig also meine Mutter schon ganz
früher gesagt ja ich bin einfach nur
wenig Selbstdisziplin und ich habe schon
lästige Sachen gerne
erfolgreich
mache ich das auch ein Stück weit also
ich kenne das zum Beispiel mega gut dass
sie mit vorwärts komme und bin ins
Internet
was für Temperatur auf der Ferieninsel
nach der Nordsee ist angegangen und dann
danke ich muss
Massageprogramm geht und wenn man schon
wissen ob es der Bäcker immer noch gibt
und schon drinnen
oder was auch immer
ja wirklich das klassische
dopaminsucht Junkie Ding oder du
brauchst irgendwie schneller schneller
Reiz irgendein und es ist völlig egal
was du willst nicht irgendwie einfach
die pflichter für Leute vielleicht zwei
Stunden dort
laut
ganz viel unter Prokrastination das ist
ernsthaft das Problem nein gesagt sogar
Krankheit
und der schuldgefühlschrank
bin psychotherapeutische Dienst will
offenbar so viel studieren die
Unternehmer
seit 20% oder bist du 20%
einfach chronischer
Studenten
sich denn wenn du Programm
also es leidet ja oft andere Personen
drunter du kennst
du eine Futter
zum Thema Prokrastination etwas Schönes
Philosophen und Philosophien
korrigieren Luthers
und gleichzeitig
vornimmt und den Augen setzt und die
aggressiva die Willensschwäche die man
ist total es ist einfach das große Drama
denn im Leben
ich kriege in besten
hoch das mache
das Mega weit berühmt Experiment mit
sogenannten Marshmallows oder zwei
mitgemacht natürlich vorbereitet Kinder
Diagnose gesetzt und gesagt ich gehe
jetzt kurz zusammen wenn du da nicht ist
und Max
herrlicher
ablenken
gemacht
und der hat sogar langzeitstudio gemacht
was natürlich sehr
interessante
der belohnungs heißt das also ich weiß
beruhigt und er später und ich habe
warte ich habe die Selbstkontrolle dass
dir im Leben erfolgreicher wurde sind
und der glücklicher das ist interessant
parallel werden wenn du gut hast du die
erste Bedürfnisse nicht im Handy nur
sportresultat sondern an
Konzept da bleiben denn wir schaffen
aber du sagst du bist
ich glaube
Extremfall und ich glaube es wird je
älter ich werde mir sehr schlimmer gar
nichts gefühlt
oder du musst dich immer sauber
schlimm um mich bestellt aber
Doktorarbeit
aber nicht ja wir sind natürlich
interessiert wie der das machen
oder verschieben ich Kommentar und jetzt
reden wir darüber was machen machen
die wichtigsten Sachen auf Platz 1 und 2
und nachher schreibt nicht so wichtige
Sache und die Zeiten selber ausdrücken
dass man die nicht so wichtige Sachen
auf Platz 1 und 2 schreibt und die
wirklich wichtig
probiert funktioniert
nein das funktioniert überhaupt nicht
mehr ich weiß nicht
extrem wichtig finde ist verstorben
Perfektionismus
und ich danke dir also diesmal richtig
zieht und ich werde ein super guten Art
alles perfekt abdecken möglichst viel
likes und kriegst du den Schritt
natürlich von vorne rein da und will ihn
nicht fertig werden
weniger perfektionistisch
Management geschrieben
wahrscheinlich
diskernen
Mann Mama
wirklich also ich glaube das ist die
aktiviere Energie wo wo wo du sagte
ausdrucken also damit der
Reaktionen Energie und du machst dass du
das Ritual das stimmt
eigentlich mit diesem noch nicht mit dem
richtigen
und das ist schon mega nervig wenn du
die Bibliothek setzten Stunde
[Gelächter]
aber bei vielen Sachen Gottes recht gut
sie warum das so ist das besprechen wir
jetzt noch ich habe das Buch klasse vom
Oliver Burgman das heißt 4000 Wochen mit
so einer Banane wo langsam voll wird
vorne
ein interessante beobachtete
und umgekehrt verzählt
bewusster typisch wo immer alles
pünktlich erledigt hat und dort damit
alles perfekt schön Justin time während
andere sind und der Zusammenhang das
wäre prokrastiniert dass man
der Autor mit der sogenannten seven
sinking steps
extrem erfolgreiche
Experiment wo jeder Management Seminar
auftaucht und das hättest du mit deiner
Sache da nämlich die Vorstellung
also E-Mail geschrieben
und jetzt natürlich das alles überhaupt
gar kein Platz mehr und dann habe ich
immer frustriert wie es wäre um die
Steigungen und jetzt hinter Steven
Corvey
seid völlig klar
packen denn die mittelgroße Sachen und
dann die kleine und dann hat alles
platzen Tag
oder und noch einer das Wort irgendwie
mehr Lust hast
Sachen muss ich heute machen also das
hilft mir zum Beispiel
es wird völlig ausblendet das Problem
für unsere
Schichten
wirklich darauf verständigen und
überlegen
nur zwei Platz also das ist wichtiger
der Woche oder vielleicht gar nicht
vielleicht gibt es ein großer Stein die
große Sache Glaubens Projekt die große
Reise machen was auch immer
eigentlich müsste das alles von dem
allen weniger das ist alles nee das
stimmt der Tag größer weniger schlafen
also ich glaube ehrlich gesagt sind so
richtig gut die Tipps geht es gar nicht
mit der
Prokrastination
[Musik]
ja sind eure Tipps im Umgang mit
Prokrastination schreiben unten in die
Kommentaren sind gespannt und wenn der
mehr zum Thema
Gespräch mit Theresa und dem Hartmut
Rosa zum Thema zieht und auch es ein
Stein hoch zwei zum gleichen Thema viel
Spaß damit